maintenant de quoi sera fait l'année
2020 avec nous à québec clément gignac
ce soir vice président principal et
économiste en chef à
l'industrielle-alliance clément gignac
bonsoir bonsoir
d'abord on laisse derrière nous une
année exceptionnelle faut dire sur les
marches on en parlait avec vincent de
hyères mais pas dans l'économie la
croissance a été assez faible
non c'est ça qui est paradoxal vous
savez en fait en 2019
on aurait eu droit à un ralentissement
économique la croissance économique la
plus faible au niveau mondial en dix ans
alors qu'ils ont eu de très bon marché
c'est à l'inversé 2018
on avait une bonne économie mondiale
croît c'est assez bien souvent les
profits taille d'ailleurs en hausse de
20% aux etats-unis mais la bourse comme
vous savez une talle avait livré des
rendements négatifs donc les marchés
boursiers ont tendance à poney serment
suivent exactement l'économie et regarde
plutôt en anticipation
ouais et faisons de l'anticipation un
peu pour 2020 avec vous ce soir on
connaît la plus longue période de
croissance économique historique
on ne voit pas ou ne parlent pas trop
fort de récession est ce que vous êtes
même optimiste pour 2020 oui je reste
optimiste mais vous savez gerald on
embarque maintenant à la onzième année
d'expansion économique de croissance
économique in est rompue aux états unis
sur c'est le cycle économique le plus
long la au cours des 100 dernières
années qu'on a pu répertorier
comme vous savez où je l' ai déjà dit
les cycles économiques ça me fera pas de
vieillesse et le fait que les banques
centrales ont vraiment fait un virage à
180 degrés on ne parle plus de
normaliser des taux on parle que les
taux d'intérêt vont rester faibles
pendant longtemps aussi longtemps de
l'inflation de sexe et les repos ça
c'est des conditions gagnantes pour une
poursuite ce qui est connu mais alors
poursuite du cycle économique avec des
taux faibles
madame lagarde qui dirige maintenant la
banque centrale européenne 1,10 1,20
vite même les pays à investir à
emprunter à faire des déficits
oui pour les pays qui ont quand même un
bilan comme exemple l'allemagne ou que
la dette nette du gouvernement
relativement faible à ce moment là
d'utiliser l'outil fiscal parce que vous
vous savez en europe qu aux mains des
taux négatifs qui lui arrive le dizaine
d'années et on voit que finalement les
allemands loin de pouvoir dépenser
épargner davantage
qui fait en sorte que ça fonctionne
votre succès et s'est créé au titre de
la distorsion puisque ça amène de
certains éleveurs à prendre plus de
risques et ne devrait donc madame
lagarde qui est l'ancien président vous
savez du fonds monétaire international
avec toute sa crédibilité à ancien
ministre des finances également de la
france va mettre beaucoup de pression
sur les pays européens pour qu'ils
utilisent l'outil budgétaire pour
maintenir et soutenir l'économie de
résident rubrique a fait un sondage
auprès de dizaines et dizaines
d'économistes pour faire les prévisions
2020 aux états unis 1,8 pour cent en
au canada un v6 la france 1,2 le
royaume-uni 1 % l'allemagne 0,6 l'italie
0.5 le japon 0,3 ça demeure quand même
dit croissance faible oui mais il faut
voir qu'on n'y aura pas on parle
peut-être même une certaine
réaccélération on est en pleine
récession dans le secteur manufacturier
non pas qu'on parlait d'une récession
économique au niveau global mais dans le
secteur manufacturier
certains pays sont en récession donc on
commence à voir avec des conditions
monétaires qui sont beaucoup plus la
supplie et la fin au sida en vue du
brésil tout ça a amené beaucoup
d'incertitudes salle affectée même le
climat d'affaires en aura une certaine
remontée mais ce que je remarque
également c'est que le canada la
croissance permet du canada des états
unis vont être beaucoup plus proche ans
en 2020 et moi j'exclus pas un gerald
que mène la croissance du canada puisse
éventuellement d'ici un an ou deux
dépassé celle des etats-unis puisque
notre croissance démographique est
beaucoup plus rapide maintenant qu'un
dock aux états unis grâce à
l'immigration
on accueille proportionnellement à notre
économie beaucoup plus d'immigrants
maintenant qu aux etats unis
oui parce que si on donne des chiffres
en valeur absolue aux états unis et
alors qu'on avait à l'époque 1.2 million
de nouveaux immigrants chaque année
maintenant est tombé à 600000 et au
conte au canada c'est un conteur l'un
accélérations ont soin de leur
maintenance de quatre cent mille
migrants et contenus de nos populations
et dix fois plus petit que les états
unis mais ça fait une différence c'est
ce qui fait que la croissance
démographique au canada votre caisse
mène 2 1 % par année supérieure aux
états unis donc tout sauf faut faire en
sorte que le pib parce que c'est
détourné par la croissance démographique
et les gains de productivité vont
commencer à rassembler
mais aux états unis et savoie l'impact
de leurs que les indiqué ce qui stimule
l'économie canadienne également et
écouter évidemment les comics indienne
n'est pas uniquement relié aux
ressources naturelles oui lui des vents
contraires du côté du pétrole
on peut voir on ne voulait que la
nouvelle économie l'été jean sortie à la
région de montréal et de toronto mais
aussi toute cette immigration la force
aux gamins parce que ces gens là doivent
se loger une bonne poussée dans
l'immobilier
on le voit dans le secteur des mises en
chantier ont d'abord au delà de 20 200
millions unités par année
donc tout ça crée de l'économie et de
l'activité dans le secteur des services
également qu'il va très bien que va
faire la banque du canada selon - la
balance que doit on ne fera rien cette
année
mais si une banque qui doit monter les
taux avant l'autre ce sera promet la
banque du canada avant la réserve
fédérale puisque le taux directeur qui
dans le fond en terme réel est plus
faible aux états unis parce que le taux
d'inflation plus élevé ou qu'un dock aux
états unis donc promet que la bande ce
que d'affreux rien dans les neuf
prochains mois
mais on pourrait certainement voir la
banque du canada se met en mode action
avant la réserve fédérale 6 1 et un
ennemi est ce sa voix influencés dans
leur casier moi je fais prédictions
gérard que d'occasion sera pas très loin
des 80 82 sous à la fin de cette année
ah oui on est à 67 ans ce moment à peu
près là où et à quelle heure années qu
on végète la vraie valeur du dollar
canadien gerald est beaucoup plus autour
des trucs cadre bien 2,84 sous mais
évidemment ça dépend du prix du pétrole
est également de la capacité de
transporter du pétrole
à l'extérieur on a senti un apaisement
avec la chine mais lol instabilité avec
l'iran comment vous placer ce nouvel
élément la géopolitique qui vient
d'arriver en début d'année vous savez ça
prend des experts puis même les experts
en géopolitique se confondent sont
confondus à la réalité c'est toujours
des éléments qui amène une prime de
risque et ça pourrait affecter
évidemment les marchés boursiers c'est
pour ça que on devrait avoir des
rendements positifs à la bourse mais à
des cuves est beaucoup moins
impressionnant puisque y aurait
certainement une prime de risque locaux
liés à l'approvisionnement pétrolier
en tout cas c'est sûr que c'est clos au
moyen-orient et ça va affecter et v mais
les marchés boursiers mais c'est
pourrait paradoxalement faire en sorte
que le marché canadien va faire mieux
que le marché américain étant donné que
les ressources naturelles sont beaucoup
plus importants dans les 10 canadien
clément gignac
merci beaucoup et bonne année complaisez
bonne année également